le piton de la fournaise un atout
incontestable pour attirer les touristes
du monde entier mais également pour
attirer les réunionnais fort de ce
constat le conseil départemental et ses
partenaires l'état et la région lodève
le parc sous l'égide du comité
d'orientation stratégique du tourisme se
sont entendus sur deux axes de
développement le premier une
reconstruction totale du gîte du volcan
et un appel à projets pour la
construction d'un éco lodge à proximité
du site du volcan bas et du conseil
celui que nous avons aujourd'hui offre
une capacité de 60 68 ce qui est encore
largement insuffisant puisque c'est un
des sites les plus fréquentés avec
presque onze mille nuitées à l'année et
donc nous construisons un nouveau gîte
plus grande capacité
différents types d'hébergement un gîte
avec une plus grande capacité d'accueil
répond dans des normes précises en
matière d'environnement d'autonomie
énergétique d'intégration dans le
paysage l'écolodge du volcan devra
répondre aux mêmes critères avec pour
objectif de protéger et valoriser le
patrimoine réunionnais pour les
réunionnais il s'agit également de
répondre à une forte demande et à une
qualité de service pour offrir aux
touristes un produit d'exception un site
d'exception comme celui du volcan peut
offrir également la construction d'un
habitat d'exception comme il en existe
dans le monde entier mais il en existe
pas beaucoup il ya à peine aujourd'hui
une vingtaine dé cologne dans le monde
qui connaissent un succès international
aux états unis en afrique du sud en
pleine savane par exemple et donc nous
nous avons validé l'idée d'un éco lodge
sur le site du volcan pourquoi parce que
lapointe bon peu pays des volcans et de
la zone océan indien
même dans l'hémisphère dans l'hémisphère
sud
après bon peut donc il faut se saisir de
cette opportunité
une valorisation du patrimoine existant
par l'activité économique
l'une des priorités de cette mandature
la sélection d'un porteur de projet
validé par les membres du cost devrait
mettre cette belle initiative sur les
rails
nature qui consiste quand même à
valoriser un patrimoine existant par
l'activité économique vous savez les
chiffres de l'insee aujourd'hui sont là
nous avons la fréquentation touristique
y qui reprend qui augmente depuis 2015
je crois qu'il nous faut avoir et ce
site en tous les cas cette volonté
d'optimiser ce site montre bien là et
bien une stratégie qui consiste
réellement à être recalibrés ja désirs
nos équipements par rapport à l'afflux
touristique suscité de l'activité
suscité de l'activité pour créer de la
richesse tout en mettant en avant une
valorisation et une identité culturelle
qui est la nôtre donc sur ces sites
emblématiques puisqu'il est prévu de
lancer l'appel à projet en début d'année
2010 est courant de l'année 2010 est un
ensemble de porteurs de projets sera
même de nous pour proposer proposé au
département de la réunion conseil
départemental différents projets qui
seront alors examinées afin de retenir
le meilleur projet sur le plan
environnemental sur le plan patrimonial
sur le plan de l'intégration paysagère
et environnementale en 2015 ce sont 4
126 mille 400 touristes qui sont venus à
la réunion
ecology la construction d'un nouveau gie
qui sera livrée en 2019 devrait
permettre d'augmenter considérablement
ce chiffre et faire de la réunion
destination unique à l'image du piton de
la fournaise qui est le troisième volcan
après le kilauea sur l'île d'hawaï de
l'etna en italie avec le plus actif au
monde